اخر الانباء عن عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
للرعايه الاجانب من السودان
يعني فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء التي
بدات منذ نحو ثلاثه ايام منذ يوم الجمعه
والسبت والاحد هذه الايام شهدت بدايه
انطلاقه عمليات الاجلاء عن طريق ميناء
بورسودان عن طريق البحر يعني ذكرت لنا
مصادر رسميه هنا في قياده القوات البحريه
وقياده القياده العسكريه هنا بانها تشرف
على عمليات
التفويج للذين يعني يحتاجون لعمليات
الاجلاء من الرعايه الدول العربيه
والافريقيه
والاوروبيه كذلك هناك يعني عدد وسلسله من
عمليات الاجلاء بدات بالفعل هنا عن طريق
سفن بعضها حربيه وبعضها تجاريه منذ يوم
الجمعه
قامت الجهات هناك غرفه مشتركه رسميه هنا
تقوم بعمليات الاجلاء وتشرف عليها بشكل
مباشر وتقوم بتسهيل عمليات النقل وعمليات
والاجراءات المكمل
لمساله السفر والتفريج عبر البحر هنا في
مدينه بورسودان عبر ميناء بورسودان
يعني الميناء الرئيس للبلاد وهو يقع في
الناحيه الشماليه الشرقيه ويبعد نحو الف
كيلو متر شمال شرق العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذه العمليات لا تزال مستمره
ويتوقع ان يعني يكون هناك عدد او سلسله من
عمليات الاجلاء هناك جنسيات مختلفه يوم
الجمعه الماضيه تم تفويج اكثر من
اربعه وخمسين شخصا تم اجلائهم عبر ميناء
بورسودان وهم يحملون جنسيات عربيه وجنسيات
افريقيه وجنسيات
اوروبيه كذلك بينهم بينهم رعايه دول رعايه
سعوديون بينهم دبلوماسيون السعوديون اذا
هم
157 شخصا تم ايلاؤهم عبر ميناء بورسودان
هذه العمليات طبعا مستمره وفي يوم السبت
الماضي ايضا تم
مجموعه من الموظفين من دوله جيبوتي تم
ايلاؤهم ايضا عبر ميناء بورسودان عبر
سفينه تجاريه تم اجلائهم الى بلادهم طبعا
عمليات الاجلاء عبر في السودان تتم عبر
ثلاثه منافذ هي منافذ بحريه ومنافذ جويه
وبطبيعه الحال هناك ايضا المنافذ البريه
عبر ولايه القضارف في الحدود الشرقيه
للسودان خاصه تلك
المتاخمه اثيوبيا عمليات الاجلاء التي تمت
عبر البر تتم من الخرطوم
ومرورا بمدينه القضارف التي تبعد نحو 600
اكثر من 600 كيلو متر في للجهه الشرق لجهه
الشرق هذه المدينه تقوم باستقبال الوافدين
اليها من الجنسيات المختلفه في من مدينه
الخرطوم التي تشهد اشتباكات متفرقه في
الواقع ما بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع يعني جعلت هؤلاء
الرعايه من عدد من الجنسيات المختلفه
اوروبيون
عرب وافارقه ايضا يعني يهمون بالفرار
والخروج من ما وصفوه بانها بؤره توتر لذلك
يعني كانوا حريصين للوصول الى مدينه
القضارف ثم بعد ذلك هناك غرفه
لعمليات الاجلاء تشرف عليها حكومه ولايه
القضارف وتقوم بعدد من الاجراءات منذ
عمليه الاستقبال الاولى للوافدين عبر
الحافلات الى مدينه القضارف ثم بعد ذلك
تقوم يعني تسهيل عمليه الخروج الامن عبر
الحدود الى اثيوبيا وعدد من الدول الاخرى
عبر اثيوبيا طبعا الدوله المتاخمه للسداد
السودان للجهه الغربيه
تمت بالفعل عمليات ايلاع عبر ولايه بعرف
خاصه وان هناك يعني مئات من الطلاب
الجامعيين يعني من جامعه افريقيا العالميه
يحملون جنسيات افريقيه مختلفه منهم يعني
من جيبوتي منهم اثيوبيون ومنهم صوماليون
تمت عمليه ايلائهم بالفعل عبر الطريق
البري
والى وصولا الى اثيوبيا طبعا عمليه
الاجلاء الجوي هنا الميناء الوحيد هنا
الميناء الجوي الوحيد او المطار الوحيد في
السودان الذي يعملها تتم عبره عمليه
الاجلاء بشكل مستمر بدات بالفعل عمليه
الايلاء الجوي من مطار بار سودان امس مساء
تم اجلاء اكثر من 400 يعني شخص من رعايه
الاردن الذين كانوا يقيمون في السودان
وبينهم دبلوماسيون وبينهم السفير الاردني
الذي كان مرافقا لرعاياه في هذه الرحلات
هذه الرحلات تمت على متن اربعه طائرات
عسكريه كانت رابطه في مطار بورسودان ووصلت
نهارا وانتظرت حتى اكتمال كل الاجراءات
المصاحبه لعمليه الاجلاء عبر مطار
بورسودان الدولي وتتم طبعا عمليه الاله
لاستقدام
يعني جوازات السفر فقط بالنسبه للمسافرين
يعني شهدنا زحاما امس كانت الجزيره داخل
مطار بورسودان وكاله شاهده على عمليه اول
عمليه اجلاء تتم عبر مطار بورسودان ويتوقع
ان تكون هناك عدد من سلسله من عمليات
الاجلاء الجوي بحسب مصادر في مطار طور
سودان علمنا ان هناك عدد من الطائرات هبطت
خلال الساعات الماضيه وليله امس بغ اجلاء
بعض الرعايه هناك طائره مصريه هبطت اليوم
وهي الان في مطار بورسودان ايضا لنقل
رعايه الدول
لنقل الرعايه المصريين او بعضهم طبعا
وهناك ايضا طائره كوريه بحسب ما تحصلنا
عليه من معلومات من مصادر الطيران المدني
هنا في مدينه بارصودان ان هذه الطائره
ايضا يعني هبطت مساء امس وتنتظر وصول
رعايه كوريين الى مطار بورسودان حتى تكتمل
اجراءاته اجلائهم والسفر عبر هذه الطائرات
يتوقع
الساعات القليله القادمه يعني استمرار
عمليات الاجلاء عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
وكذلك عبر
الميناء الرئيسي ميناء بورسودان علمنا ان
ايضا ان هناك يعني ما لا يقل عن